so hi my boy so I watch pitch perfect 3
the morning after the glamour Christmas
party so you're feeling fresh means
beautiful glowing gorgeous obviously but
it was hilarious and it was the best
hangover remedy and if you've got a
hangover what do you like to do okay
this is a good thing but I've never in
my life been drunk what I know people
think I'm a big alkie yeah yeah you
understand yeah but I'm I'm normally I'm
so busy that I only have to work the
next day
and so I can't get smashed I don't think
I mean nobody not wrong but I don't
think I've ever been smashed enough to
have to have a I do like though a Baraka
oh yeah so in this movie and a Mia
singles but she did not give a damn
about that that's what I loved in the
movie
yeah and anyway she had far more
pressing concerns to worry about and now
we're fully in party season who do you
think amy was like to get under the
mistletoe oh so like ever anyone out
there anyone in the world I mean I was
gonna say Prince Harry and he's taken
damn new mega dad I was so quiet now I
was never closed who else would I say I
mean Channing Tatum he's always one of
my classic guide to any if you bust out
some shapes well you know not why you
would sing but afterwards yeah yeah who
else I mean we the I mean I love working
with Adam Devine who plays bumper and
yeah who's not in pitch perfect 3 so
what we actually did was film a whole
other movie that'll come out next year
it's a romantic comedy we play different
characters but my agent was like well if
Ryan Gosling and Emma Stone is like you
guys yeah do it in another movie and so
we did so for the bumper and fat Amy
fans though they'll see us in another me
you can't wait for that and so either
season embarrass myself at my croissant
party but have you
I've been at a party and embarrassed
yourself I didn't had a fall or anything
listen back yeah I've done that terrible
thing where you know there's furniture
that's made of like mica I guess I call
it and I've like snagged like ripped
things I've like gotten out of a car and
my Spanx of rips all down the back and
you're like what the hell am I gonna do
like I'm just arriving at the party I've
done so many embarrassing things I also
spill food on myself all the time pretty
much every second day there's some kind
of food slope that doesn't make me look
very sophisticated and so what do you
think Amy wore ask Santa for this year
[Music]
well what will that rebel as funds for
the show I asked I did just receive some
personalized Tim Tams
oh I mean we don't get like they somehow
I don't know how they did them but they
have my name on the packaging that to do
sweet pretty cool mm-hmm anything with
your name on is like the best it's
personalized yeah obviously Christmas is
all about that karaoke life and
obviously it's perfect all about singing
and what Christmas song is your go-to
like classic I like um the Mariah Carey
songs on the wrong note then I didn't go
for the hits right you need to get a job
I'm not warming up but that song I mean
that song is a killer
it's amazing puppy it's like it gets a
potty going is it's on everything globe